the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
you won't see my name on the door of any
convenience store you won't see my name
on the door of any box store or
a bank that says you got to wear a mask
tonight on politics now former senator
dean heller jumping into the race for
governor we ask about covid election
rules and trump plus
there's three sort of unsolvable issues
at this point that all of government is
approaching i think you should open that
up to the public and you should
have uh those meetings in your community
so that you can get actual real-time
feedback so far two men are vying for
clark county sheriff we talked to them
about their approaches to fighting crime
and changes they would make in the
department and another potential
government shutdown looming right now we
explain the process democrats want to
use to avoid it
from 8 news now this is politics now
former republican senator dean heller
making it official good evening i'm
david charns and this week for john
langler heller announcing his run for
the republican nomination for governor
in carson city monday and then we got a
chance to talk to him as he stopped here
in las vegas issue number one he says
the pandemic and democratic governor
steve sisilak's handling of it
i have been
immunized my wife has been immunized my
family has been immunized and i think
that's very important and i'll continue
to stress
to nevadans because i think that's the
only way that's the only way you can
combat uh this virus is to get immunized
that's the answer if you're immunized
and i am doesn't mean i'm not going to
get covered but the chance of getting a
bad case of it obviously is diminished
pretty substantially i want to make one
thing clear from the offset on this is
that i don't support mandates
and i do not support
lockdowns and will not support them in
the future
now to become the republican party's
nominee heller is going to have to bring
together all sides of the gop so here's
what he said about getting president
trump's base on his side
i think it's going to be just fine one
i'm the only proven conservative in this
race i think that most conservatives are
tired i think most nevadans for that
matter are tired of seeing a
six-year-old child or their children and
their grandchildren running around on a
soccer field wearing masks i think
they're tired of that i think
conservative values are going to win
this race and when those conservative
values deal with crime deal with
abortion deal with
issues immigration similar to that
i've got the record for it i mean i
supported conservative judges when i was
in washington d.c i helped pass
the american first act i even helped
write it i continue to support it so i
think conservative values are going to
win this race and at the end of the day
now another big topic he talked about is
the right for women to seek abortion
heller describing himself as the at the
get-go on his website as pro-life and he
tells me he'd want to make abortion
illegal in nevada
reported the texas law this morning when
reporters asked you that that's six
weeks
uh no no exceptions um and that you
would like to bring it to to the voters
here in nevada to change what's in our
constitution can you expand on that yeah
yeah and i probably should clarify i
probably should clarify i don't really
know
everything that was in that law i like
the concept of it but i know that
they're going to have some problems some
issues and frankly it's going to be
challenged so let's see where it goes
from there
but i want the most conservative
pro-life
laws enacted in the state of nevada that
the legislature will pass that we can
work together on nevada voters would
have to vote on that as well so if it's
in our constitution that
uh you can get an abortion changes any
change back from the 1990 law but six
weeks rape and incest excluded is i mean
included is what you're looking at yes
so it's important to tell you that any
changes to abortion access here in
nevada would require a change to our
state constitution and that process
includes several votes in the
legislature where that would likely
never pass right now with the current
democratic majority and then it would go
to a statewide vote as well now i also
asked heller about the past election
well first of all i know who the
president united states is today my
question is is how bad uh was this last
election this last election was a mess
there was a lot of chaos involved in
this uh here in the state of nevada and
frankly i think the legislature when
they changed the laws from the last
legislative session made it easier and
cheat
if as secretary of state i think i know
a thing or two about election laws here
in the state of nevada they watered down
voter id they
took a felony which was a felony at one
point ballot harvesting made it what
they consider now to be good government
and multiple ballots were delivered to
the same residents
now heller tells me he's not asked for
nor has he received the former
president's endorsement heller said he'd
love to see president trump supporting
him so far the other republicans running
right now against dean heller clark
county sheriff joe lombardo north las
vegas mayor john lee reno attorney joey
gilbert and financial investor gee
norhan now congressman mark amade up
north has also said he may jump in but
no
no he hasn't done so yet of course the
winner of that race goes on to face
governor sisilak a campaign spokesperson
for the governor telling us in a
statement republicans have found
themselves in a crowded primary they
will have to fight through for the next
nine months she says in the meantime
governor sisalak will be focused on
nevada's recovery getting more shots and
arms nevadans back to work and
businesses back open and thriving
meantime i plan to let a tech company
create its own semi-autonomous
government took a head on assault from
story county the plan is called an
innovation zone and this is a rendering
from the company that wants to create
them it's called blockchain llc a bill
to create innovation zones turned into a
committee to study it and that committee
did meet this week story county
officials made clear they support plans
for the company to develop land but
pushed back on their assertions they
would need to create their own
government to do that now the committee
is supposed to come up with
recommendations before the next
legislative session
i spent decades behind a news desk
trying to be your voice and i'll do the
same as your secretary of state
that is former television journalist
gerard romalo announcing his run for
nevada's secretary of state wednesday
romalo says he will run as a republican
focusing on nevada's election system and
growing business opportunities here he
is up against two democrats cisco
aguilar and former assemblywoman ellen
spiegel and republican and former
assemblyman jim marchand well the next
top cop here in the valley
the community doesn't really feel
connected oftentimes to the police
department changing the way we police
in that we involve the community and the
folks that we do police
more so
up next we hear from both men running
for clark county sheriff about their
strategies
to get the community more involved in
what police are doing and alex limon
explaining what the heck budget
reconciliation is and how it may keep
the government from getting shut down
again
well so far two men that served quite a
long time in the metro police department
have thrown their hats in the ring for
clark county sheriff they are former
undersheriff kevin mcmahill who just
retired in december and former assistant
sheriff tom roberts who served in the
state assembly after his career at metro
ended now lombardo has endorsed mcmahill
but also has had said some nice things
about roberts so far john langler talked
to both of them this week so let's start
with kevin mcmahill and his answer to
addressing a rise in violent crime
there's three sort of unsolvable issues
at this point that all of government is
approaching right it's the homeless
issue the addiction issue and the mental
health issue and you know today
unfortunately the clark county detention
center remains the largest addiction
treatment center in the state of nevada
it's also the largest mental health
facility in the state of nevada and we
probably house more homeless in the
clark county detention center than
anywhere else and so
the other challenge that i have to tell
you with that is is typically one or all
three of those things are involved
oftentimes in the challenges that our
officers have that will ultimately end
up in an officer-involved shooting so
they're deploying crisis response teams
right now as we speak at metro that's a
licensed clinical social worker along
with a paramedic and an emt that go out
to these calls for service they're
handling about six of them per day
they're only taking place at the
convention center area command and the
downtown area command
we have 11 area commands i think it's
important that we continue to
utilize those those types of resources
to assist us sheriff lombardo now
running for governor has already sort of
supported you and your campaign to uh to
become the sheriff what of
sheriff lombardo's term as as sheriff
and your own time at metro would you
want to continue and what do you think
needs to be changed in another
administration yes so i actually have
the support of the last three sheriffs
sheriff young sheriff gillespie and of
course sheriff lombardo and i i think um
you know we've always been very
fortunate to have very good sheriffs
here um
i think that one of the things that i
certainly continue on is is that metro
has been very exceptional at crime
fighting
that's what they want from the community
wants from their police department they
want that safety and security piece of
it
one of the things that i can tell you
that i bring to the table that
that we're going to continue to improve
upon and and you know i think it's a
direct result of of some of the
challenges that all police departments
have across this
uh nation of ours is that the community
doesn't really feel connected oftentimes
to the police department and i i think
that we're better at it than most but
one of the things that i'm really going
to focus in on is that sort of authentic
community relationship building
so that we can better understand one
another in in times of crisis and we
don't have to have the challenges that
we've seen in the years past use of
force and oversight that was addressed
in the last legislative session the
attorney general's office uh being
involved now and reviewing use of force
what involvement
do you believe on an on another agency
level on the state level whatever the
case may be should metro police have for
use of force
well i think metro is a model for the
use of force piece of it i had a big
hand in creating the current model that
exists at metro not only from a
administrative investigation which looks
at policy procedure training tactics
leadership supervision of all of the
officers involved in that incident
but you know i welcome that additional
scrutiny i really do because
most people don't know i know we just
had another officer-involved shooting i
believe it was yesterday that's number
six for metro
in 2010 when we had the department of
justice come in we had 25 and so metro
is making the right steps but we still
have to find those alternatives to
deadly force and continue to train that
into our officers you're running against
tom roberts a man i'm sure you're
familiar with obviously he had a long
service with metro police as well
how
would you say you are different than
what he might bring to metro police
listen i'm not going to sit here and say
one bad word to you about tom roberts
tom did an exceptional job while he
worked for me as an assistant sheriff he
did everything i ever asked him to do
tom's a good man i just believe i'm more
qualified than tom you know everything
from the the bundy incident to uh being
in charge of one october to the uh covid
response and then obviously the summer
of unrest and rioting that we had i was
out there on the front lines with our
troops
and i just believe that my education and
experience
puts me a notch above tom and that's why
i'm running for sheriff
kevin mcmahill there now his opponent as
you just heard is tom roberts who also
spent time in the legislature here's
john's interview with him
simply put what changes would you make
if elected as sheriff from the lombardo
administration or do you think things
are moving at a reasonably good
motion right now
well look crime is up uh you know basic
all crime is up five percent this year
homicides are up 60 something percent
vehicle theft up 33 percent and i think
that we need to stay focused or my top
priority would be making las vegas the
safest
community in america and i would focus
on the basics right is
our most vulnerable population our
seniors and children and obviously our
economic engine the strip and our
tourist corridor so what's the solution
to that frequently i think a lot in law
enforcement even the sheriff
has said you know the issue would be
come down to funding or manpower
resources and so forth if elected
sheriff what's the solution to
the
spike in murders the spike in violent
crime a lot of these horrible things
that we've been seeing in our community
well i think it's a matter of changing
the way we police
in that we involve the community and the
folks that we do police
more so i think we do a decent job of it
i think we could do much better
i talked about our schools and our
seniors is actually involving them in
the policing process and telling us
where we need to focus our attention on
i think it's leveraging public-private
partnerships with the business community
and actually putting cops where they
need to be and putting them in our
neighborhoods they do these uh the first
tuesdays i think it is where they go out
into the different commands and there's
sort of events with the community
are you referring to something more than
that something more
robust than that in terms of community
and if so
how would it look so i mean we have a
comstat process which is we go over our
crime statistics on on a weekly basis
actually every morning there's a crime
call they go over go over call
go over crime that occurred in the last
24 hours but i think you should open
that up to the public and you should
have
those meetings in your community so you
can get actual real-time feedback not
only from your police officers that that
patrol the streets but you're the you
know the community that you serve one of
the issues that was brought up in the
legislative session uh in the past which
you obviously you were at dealing with
investigation of use of force and
involving the attorney general's office
in that
what is your position on that should
metro essentially investigate itself in
the use of deadly force or do you
subscribe to the idea that an outside
agency
should be responsible for that well i
believe now look i was part of that
process over the last five or six years
i think we do a very good job
of investigating our own use of force i
think it's important to have an outside
entity that would be able to audit that
or to take a look at that i think we
found several years ago when we added
the citizens review board for internal
affairs cases that our level of
investigations went up anytime you have
somebody looking at those things i think
you do a much better job and i i don't
believe that we at metro would be afraid
of that outside scrutiny and i think we
would welcome it what are the
differences between yourself and mr
mcmahon well look i think
we both have a lot of uh experience i've
got over 10 years experience in
executive staff he's got some experience
there i think some of the fundamental
differences
are from an education standpoint uh you
know i have a master's degree he doesn't
i have the highest level of post
certification
that you can have in the state he does
not i think our leadership style
varies somewhat and you'll see the
differences as this campaign continues
to roll out well tell me about your
leadership style look i believe in
collaboration and working with others i
believe in being approachable
not closed door i think
officers and should be able to get to
the fifth floor at metro right now they
can't they have to make an appointment
to get up there i think the sheriff
needs to be out in the public and i
think the sheriff needs to be out with
the troops
now both roberts and mcmahon had a lot
to say about crime fighting strategies
as well they had positive things to say
about the overall direction at metro you
can watch those full interviews on that
and what their code policies would be
for the department over on eight newsnow
dot com well a government shutdown is
looming up next alex limon explains what
budget reconciliation is
right now thousands of migrants mostly
from haiti are living under a bridge in
del rio texas at one point there were as
many as fifteen thousand people there
the body administration facing pressure
from all sides over the deteriorating
situation republicans complaining about
haitian migrants being released here
into the u.s democrats though saying the
conditions are just simply inhumane well
the federal government is now a week
from a shutdown if democrats and
republicans can't agree on a path
forward to fund our government right now
the two sides sparring over a democratic
push to attach a debt ceiling height to
that 3.5 trillion dollar spending plan
republicans are refusing to support that
effort
if they want to tax borrow and spend
historic sums of money without our input
they'll have to raise the debt limit
without our help i didn't want to vote
for it when trump was president but i
did because my obligation is to pay our
bills so that we can make veterans va
benefit payments so we can make social
security payment now the house already
passed a bill to fund the government and
raise the debt ceiling but democrats
need at least 10 republicans to pass the
plan over in the senate unless they
managed to use what is called budget
reconciliation
john langler talked with our washington
d.c correspondent alexandra limon to
explain exactly what that means
democrats are hoping to pass that 3.5
trillion dollar spending plan using
budget reconciliation it's a term we've
heard a lot about lately but
it's pretty technical alex simone
joining us from washington to to talk
about it and what this budget
reconciliation what it really is alex
hey there well budget reconciliation is
a process by which lawmakers try to pass
a budget to put it simply now in the u.s
house lawmakers always only need a
simple majority in order to pass a piece
of legislation but that is not the case
in the senate because of the filibuster
senators need to have 60 senators
support
a piece of legislation in order to pass
it the budget reconciliation however
provides an exemption to that rule any
bill that or any package that is passed
under this process of budget
reconciliation can be passed with only a
simple majority and that is why both
parties really try to use that process
when they can to try to pass major
pieces of legislation republicans for
example use that process to pass their
tax cuts which also provided you know
big tax cuts to corporations they
slashed the corporate tax rate and now
democrats are trying to do the same
thing trying to approve their spending
plan plan 3.5 trillion dollars that
would invest in things like free
preschool community college and also
make big investments in green energy to
try to fight climate change they too are
trying to pass it under budget
reconciliation which again would only
require a simple majority in the senate
so alex again as you said it's a
technical uh situation there in capitol
hill is a technical process only
requires that simple majority the
democrats there's a big push to get it
done but they still haven't gotten it
done where do things stand right now
with getting this all approved and
pushing it through
yeah although democrats have the
majority in the senate they've still not
been able to reach an agreement within
their own party in order to actually get
that done and get that budget
reconciliation package passed and that's
because there's some disagreement some
pretty big disagreement between the more
progressive members of the caucus and
then the more moderate members of the
caucus like joe manchin and kristin
cinema for example who don't agree with
various different things the large price
tag of it for example 3.5 3.5 trillion
dollars but also some of the other
measures uh west virginia obviously
being a big coal country area so joe
manchin perhaps pushing back on some of
those green energy initiatives and what
that would do for the coal industry in
his state
so we're seeing a lot of disagreement
and so far democrats have just had
trouble getting all of the members of
their own party in the senate to agree
and that was alex limon from washington
day marking four years since 1 october
in what to watch tonight there will be a
remembrance over at the healing garden
we will be covering that on 1 october
all day long here at channel 8. and as
alex just mentioned the budget runs out
tuesday we are waiting to see some kind
of continuing resolution if that passes
or
if we will have yet another government
shutdown next week thanks for watching
politics now you can stay up to date
online anytime and watch us here every
saturday night have a great night